le tours fc ne montera donc pas en
nationale 3 après 2019 2020 et 2021
nouveau veto hier soir de la commission
régionale de contrôle des clubs comme un
hamster dans sa roue laisser les noirs
sont donc une nouvelle fois condamné à
faire du surplace malgré de bons
résultats sportifs ce soir la question
même de la survie du tfc est sur la
table audrey champigny
les ciel et noir ont peut être joué la
dernière saison de leur histoire malgré
une première place au classement de
régionales une cette saison le tfc ne
montera pas en nationale 3 l'instance
régionale des clubs a rejeté le projet
et les garanties présentées par
jean-marc ettori entre incompréhension
et inquiétude le futur président délégué
du club et dans la tente d'explications
concrètes c'est un relevé de conclusions
d'une réunion qu'on a reçu non daté ni
signé en tout cas elle n'est
officiellement pas valable puisque on ne
peut pas s'en servir même si on voulait
faire appel par exemple après elle est
quand même estampillé ligue du centre
mais on ne sait pas qui nous l'a
réellement envoyer une sanction qui pèse
très lourd balayé les promesses de
futurs actionnaires balayer aussi les 25
salariés de la snp coach joueurs sans
oublier l'association tfc en
déséquilibre financier une liquidation
judiciaire serait dramatique c'est un
scénario possible et le tfc dans son
ensemble puisque je rappelle aussi que
la structure sas paix et l'association
sont liés inévitablement il ya quand
même des factures qui sont en attente de
la part de l' ssp vis-à-vis de
l'association qui si jamais il y avait
une décision
extrême de liquidation inévitablement le
liquidateur judiciaire lui
appellerait cccc facture l'a donc oui on
est sur des centaines de milliers
d'euros jean-marc ettori jettera t-il
l'eponge ou fera-t-il appel la réponse
dans les prochains jours